how are you Brian hi rich before we get
to your two cents on it um which we've
heard over the weekend and I'd love to
have you put a little bit more meat on
the bones how did this all come together
Brian
well they the pelicans wanted to get a
deal done in advance of the drafts now
sometimes I get a little skeptical when
teams create deadlines that aren't real
you know daryl morey of the Rockets is
famous for this creating deadlines to
try to force deals but I do think that
they wanted to have some time to sit
with that number four pick either to use
it or to trade it off and when the mix
sort of fell out of the bidding and it
became clear that it was going to be the
Lakers pick or I deal with the Celtics
billion was a bidding war between those
two teams and rich Paul was concerned
his agent Dan taint Davis agent was
concerned about the bidding war between
the Lakers and the Celtics as far back
as last fall and he was concerned that
the Celtics would win that bidding war
because they have players that the
pelicans prefer and so he entered into a
multi stage multi month effort to get
the Celtics to to not be able to do a
deal with the pelicans enforcement of
the Lakers at the end of the day I do
believe that's what happened
the Celtics just couldn't risk what it
would take on a player who might leave
after a year and I don't think that the
pelicans really liked the player assets
that the Lakers had they clearly didn't
like it in February when they rejected
the deal now to be clear rich I don't
think it's that they don't like Lonzo
ball and Brandon Ingram I just don't
think they like that is the bajor piece
of the trade so they took what they
could get from the Lakers which was
basically draft assets for the next five
to seven years and went to the to the
wall in terms of that to make up for the
fact that they're not in love with the
players that they're getting and that's
really the way this trade went down all
right so let me ask you you're you're
know let's get to it your two cents on
the trade do you don't like it and it
sounds like you were particularly
virulent in your dislike
well no to be clear I if you can get a
superstar player it's a major
accomplishment I always say that there's
two types of teams than the NBA teams
that have superstars and teams that wake
up dreaming of ways to get them so if
the Lakers to go to land two superstars
in two years is tremendous it is exactly
what you try to do as a front office is
layer your stars that's what those
championship contenders my point in the
night of the tray of the draft Oregon
sorry the night of the trade which he
just played them there was people were
just shrugging off what the what the
pelicans required if you had to really
look into the details of what was in
that to understand exactly what was in
that it wasn't just oh three first-round
picks let's move on it was three
first-round picks and a swap and
deferment that will give the the
pelicans control of the Lakers draft
much like the way these Nets controlled
the Celtics draft four or five years I'm
sorry these helpers control the Nets
traffics for five years now you can come
back on me on that and say well Paul
Pierce and Kevin Garnett were not
Anthony Davis and his prime totally fair
that's absolutely true but I just I just
didn't want people to glaze over the flu
you know what was in that in that trade
it was one of the steepest prices in
terms of draft cakes ever given out well
I mean and so my response to all that
would be for the Lakers they are in the
there in the LeBron James business right
now and either they're gonna you know
win with him and their final three went
you know years of his window or even
maybe somehow resize him and he finishes
his career here with Anthony Davis so
what would the draft choices really even
mean for them that's mine well again
that's what that's what people would say
that's what people said about the Nets
but the other thing is the people you
know again this is what people don't
compute because of the the training
rules
the Lakers can now not trade any future
first-round picks to help them stock the
team you can't trade picks and
back-to-back years so now with with all
of their picks and the word that they
use an NBA circles is in
Humbert they can't trade any draft specs
so like if you need to get LeBron
Anthony Davis help you no longer can use
even those even like you couldn't trade
your 2024 first-round pick for any help
and I think that was just something to
be pointed out but what you're bringing
up is what I think is the real issue
you're not the issue but the reality
which is that people keep saying well
who won the trade the Lakers or the
pelicans and the answer is LeBron won
the trade because LeBron is the guy who
you know wants to win today right now
give me a player right now if you go
look at his this is about to be a 17th
year he's only played with about maybe
three or four rookie first-round draft
pick all of his team's have always
traded their picks because it's always
win now when now when now what he's got
here basically is a Redux of 2010 in
Miami in 2014 my in the Cleveland where
he now has a top loaded roster with a
couple of stars that doesn't really have
role players yet it is going to require
him to do a lot of heavy lifting in
terms of shop creation and ball control
and everything like that we don't know
that their roster is yes we don't
completely know what it's going to be
like but the Lakers are going to have a
year here where they're probably not
going to be at their most depth and best
because of the way this went down and
that's a reality that LeBron has been
comfortable with shouldering the load in
the past it's just that in the past he
was you know eight and and five years
younger and and that's a question mark
to me so Brian when Horst here on the
Rich Eisen show so a couple more
questions on on the trade right here and
then we'll move towards about the future
of this trade and the immediacy of that
fourth overall selection does this get
done if David Griffin's not there I mean
how much is the change of landscape in
the front office of New Orleans mean for
this trade Brian
I don't know it's a really good question
I don't know I mean I definitely think
that there was there was animus that
existed between Dell Demps and Magic
Johnson and the reason that happened is
because whether it's true or not whether
it's fair or not the the pelicans
thought that the Lakers were complicit
in wrecking their season and again I'm
not saying that that's even true but
they looked at them as being a factor in
Anthony Davis demanding a trade and you
know and so I think part of that had to
calm down because it almost may have
been anybody in that seat I don't you
know I don't think Grif was in would
have made this deal in this particular
fashion had he not had number one pick
in the draft I really do think that the
lottery the events of lottery night
really helped this happen because number
one you have a new franchise player that
you know you're gonna have I don't know
how good is going to be but you were
gonna lose Anthony Davis in a year
anyway and now you have a replacement
for your fans or replacements to build
around then with number one pick in the
draft was enormous and then the Lakers
jumping in a huge move forward from 11th
to force which in which increase the
value of that and that's the other thing
about this about this trade rich the
pelicans aren't even that enamored with
a number four pick I mean they've been
trying to trade it for almost a week now
so and there's a decent chance that
they're gonna trade it I don't think
that they're like boy if we could just
get this guy and tear him his eye on so
like David Griffin made the trade that
he had to make probably not the trade
that he wanted to make when another
general manager have come to the same
conclusion I don't know but fair
question so which team is the most out
of luck
that that Griffin made the deal with the
Lakers the wanted Anton Davis had the
Knicks have had an absolutely horrible
ten days not as bad as those two
warriors ten days the Knicks have been
at least at this point have been really
big losers here because they were hoping
to get Durant and Kyrie together and if
they did it in a certain way and Durant
and Kyrie were amenable they could even
a flip the number three
taken some other people on their team
France any day like that would have been
a long shot but I could have gettin
gotten a whiteboard in front of you and
showed you how it was possible to have
those three guys on the same team and
that's a that's a championship team
instantaneously I mean we're talking
about major major greatness coming out
of out of New York and we know that
there's something that they dreaming
about for months because they traded
chris that porzingis what the exact
intention of trying to pair these
superstars so in the course of a week
Anthony Davis gets traded to LA where he
is now what they going to stay Kyrie
Irving sends every message in the book
that he's headed towards the Brooklyn
Nets and Kevin Durant has a terrible
injury knocks him out for a year and
completely throws his he turns a
question I mean it's only July it's
always June 16th I can't tell you where
everyone's rosters are gonna be but very
bad week for next fans in my viewpoint
Brian when horse in the Honda inside a
report here in the Rich Eisen show let's
talk about next steps what is the next
step in terms of when this deal gets
finalized and how that breaks down best
you can lay it out with all the minutiae
Brian well a big factor is what happens
for the number four pick the number four
pick is dealt before the draft there's a
possibility that this becomes a straight
three-way trade and that there could be
some other pieces that get involved with
the Lakers again with the pelicans I
mean for example I know that the
pelicans are interested in moving
Solomon Hill out you know there's a
bunch of different possibilities to come
into play there's from what I hear three
to five teams that are talking to the
pelicans about that number four pick now
will they get something that they like
enough to train it you know that's a
different conversation but this trade
could morph and when when a trade morph
ye could include three teams that could
include four teams right now if I was
the Lakers I'm looking at all of my
options in terms of free agency the
Lakers have now landed the biggest trade
piece we've seen in some time my
colleagues act lo thinks it's the
biggest trade pieces cream abdul-jabbar
he thinks
that kind of move so it's a huge moment
for them but they now have between 23
and 30 million dollars to spend in free
agency and while I'm sure they're going
to put in calls to the Kawhi Leonard's
and Kyrie Irving's of the world this is
a good year to have space because
there's a 35 for some of the League of
the free agent there's a whole bunch of
other guys out there well I think that
really helps the Lakers and that aren't
max players that are there are sub max
players that you could fill out your
roster with just like kind of like the
team has just won the title they had one
supernova and a whole bunch of really
good players and that if I were the
Lakers would be very instructive to me
well give me some names Brian throw it
out there for me play polenka you won't
miss you know right well the first thing
I would say is take last year's strategy
and light it on fire where they
discussed 99 shooters every single
person who they sign must be a shooter
so I'm looking at guys like Brook Lopez
who they let go a year ago I'm looking
at guys like JJ Redick I'm looking at
guys like Danny Green you're not holding
a parade for any of those arrivals but
all of them could be very helpful I'm
looking at a guy like Boyan Bogdanovich
you usually have to be an NBA fan to
know who he is but but he has that a
brilliant year with the Pacers last year
would be a perfect set I'm even and this
is a incredible name but I'm looking at
a guy like D'Angelo Russell who yeah was
sent out with sent packing by the Lakers
two years ago but the people who sent
him packing and the circumstances of why
he was sent packing have kind of
dissipated and if Kyrie Irving signs in
Brooklyn there's a possibility that the
Nets will let him walk he's young as
exactly the type of player that the
Lakers need now whether he would want to
go back there is a different story but
you've got to find shooting shoot even
JJ's I say JJ Redick Dozier etics
shooting shooting shooting shooting
shooting experience experience
experience because you now simply saying
this is going to be a two to three year
window
let's get guys who can help us win right
now that's the Detroits that they have
made and they better back that up with
the with moves in that direction well
and then
last one for you on this Brian when
worst so what what if the Lakers do go
the we want to get the the big star and
it's either dated to the point where
they could max this person out best they
could or that person decides to just
wait around or takes less to just get to
the Lakers right now is Kemba Walker a
reality could that be a guy that they
look at which also would stick another
pin in the Knicks plan if something like
that happens what do you think about
that Brian okay well I think the ideal
player for them right now is a guy who
can handle the ball but doesn't have to
handle the ball and can create his own
shot but also be a spot-up shooter the
most ideal player ever to play with
these two guys is is Kyrie Irving I mean
basically this would be that the
Cleveland team that won the title with a
huge upgrade from Kevin Love to Anthony
Davis Kyrie Irving is maybe the you've
heard me say this to you before Kyrie
Irving is maybe the best suited teammate
LeBron has ever had not maybe the best
teammate but where their skill sets
match but Kyrie and LeBrons
personalities off the floor and even on
the floor times don't mesh that's not a
reality so Kemba Walker is a reasonable
comparison to Kyrie Irving they do some
of the same things but Kemba I mean for
Kevin to leave a potential five-year
offer in Charlotte which I don't know if
he's going to get but if they get the
five-year offers Charlotte he's leaving
tens of millions on the table to leave
even more money to sign for less than
the max I mean I suppose as possible I
don't I haven't spoken to Kim but since
the trade so I can't say how he's
thinking but I mean yes if your answer
is what he fit yes do I see that working
with their current salary structure I
would be surprised okay and then last
one the the Kawhi aspect of it right now
he's at a parade what's the timeframe
what are the thoughts
obviously everybody here in Los Angeles
Laker fans dreaming of him adding his
name to this remarkable mix and of
course the clipper fans hoping that he
comes and does for them what he did for
Toronto what do you make of this Brian
right now yeah cool Kawhi kind of in the
same position LeBron was a year ago
he has a blackjack disguise the two-time
champion just completely led this team
to the promised land in a tight window
because of the you know the scenario
that existed and the Warriors injuries
and everything like that I mean he can
do whatever you want
he doesn't have to go somewhere to chase
a championship he doesn't have to go
somewhere to to you know to try to prove
himself Kauai is gonna do what makes
Kauai happy and that's a great position
to be in and and you know the Toronto
fans will be devastated if you left but
they can't be mad at it's like the
Cleveland fans couldn't be mad at LeBron
so to me you're what the real question
is what makes Kawhi Leonard happy is
being on a team with the FA Davis LeBron
James that answer I don't think so but
if you know it makes Kawhi happy rich
I'd like to congratulate you and offer
you lots of money to go run a team
because nobody seems to know Bryan
you're the best thanks to the call we're
gonna call you again real soon you can
bet on that thanks to the call you go
that's Bryan win horst for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app